y'all welcome to this video I've salad
in new gay Mia and playing a once again
against the teammate of mine let's see
what happens we have on an English
Defence with b6 and I playing with e3 it
so it's a bit similar to the NIMS oh but
black gum still has the option yeah
exactly i play with f5 so it's not
exactly an absorb but similar alright so
let's put this night on a form so that
any moves with the deep one of our
problem are not easily played at least
and I'm attending at the right moment to
play d 5 but first I'd like to see a
black set up okay
I'm not sure shouldn't be too bad on
yeah okay but isn't this very weakening
I can't really believe that is able to
take I mean no no F for this looks a
rather radically now he will he will
need to give up squares now and these
squares that you really don't want to
give up GTX it takes e4 9f to Bishop e3
and G form at the end of all this so
takes takes e4 night f2 and that I
prepared reform ya can try that here at
least I'm unable to immediately go to e6
but I can prepare that night beehive to
fall as soon as there is one possibility
the other idea here is to play Bishop to
deform you know it's also quite good
yeah and I don't really want the night c
5 22
okay so at the end of all this there's
the e6 square
yeah rookie six is one idea yeah b5
shell to be 2nite to be too
night to be too it doesn't look like
very powerful moves yeah now he's
threatening on d5 but really why to be
too let's go here at least maybe night
h1g three years as possible
hmm
yeah I didn't like to give up the bishop
but okay it's a it's still fine I
control the vital square CRE 64 rookie 6
i'm attacking the f porn here it is a
plane for counter-attack maybe just drop
this back it's an under fire anyway yeah
night to d4 would be almost all most
deadly but still this is hanging
maybe I should just just play that yeah
it's um yeah okay it's a not really
important if it takes the exchange
f5 I need to win this pawn Knight e to d
for a five and then it all breaks down
maybe maybe we'll see eight intending
Luke's III it's a possible counter play
now yeah rook c8 sir the move okay the
movie to now on kiss he's still getting
2 33 okay
getting getting this temple and now this
one night g3 to e4 yeah now he's got
some counter play whoopsie one maybe I
should just take it it's probably better
just attack here and now Roxy one still
looks you wanna let the mount is not
threatening much i can i can improve
I have fun the white light squares
controlled mostly it's only this this
irritating rook moves I was thinking of
night f45 again but he's got Luke's III
forgot about that oh yeah forgot about
that as well
okay yes it is lost but let's try a bit
at least I'm warning
yep it's mostly just uh just to just
just some checks it's not not much more
admittedly
hmm
it's not even i don't even have checks
yeah some kind of trick are the Queen
Queen check him and I didn't play them
even yeah I will sometime anyway yeah
this is of course a bit disappointing it
was certainly just winning from white
rhodium everything else would surprise
me greatly it's just + 15 just 0.5 and
that's amazing okay this blonde us to
roots III I overlooked that and it's not
the wind this is surprising maybe if the
computer is given a bit more time quite
interesting I really thought this is
just over that probably is but it's it's
not not trivial the comp is just on 0.6
so not like plus 2 or something which I
expected Bishop d5 it gives us the best
move on now Queen f4 yeah possible
yeah complicated I mean it was really a
position that was very comfortable and
you can play all kinds of moves maybe
this wasn't even the best I don't know I
mean it certainly needs to a good
position but it's not not entirely clear
I defended this very tenaciously okay
this is quite logical all of that maybe
ever okay this is not a big deal I need
to really play this one just keeping
keeping the position as is and then try
to improve he cannot really do much I
have all this controlled I played Queen
III and this allowed Roxy three here
this is difficult and difficult to make
a move / black society problem if you
play something like this f6 just wins so
he needs to play some some not so
committal and then there's this is not a
form but there it's a look at one end
and a black is still alive a computer as
it's not feel positive about this for
white hmm interesting yeah interesting
game thanks for watching